Ciao maryners e benvenuti in questo nuovissimo videooo
Allora come vedete ho una pettinatura un po bizzarra perché mi
Ricordava molto quelle che mi facevo da piccola e infatti questo video parlerà di make up ma, non
del make up
attuale cioè quello che va di moda adesso o quello che mi faccio adesso
dei make up che mi facevo quando ero piu piccola infatti mi avete scritto tante volte 'ma tu maryna come ti truccavi alle medie, al liceo..
dacci qualche consiglio', ecco diciamo che non seguirete mai questi miei consigli perché mi truccavo da schifo però almeno vi farete due risate
quindi vi sto per far vedere dei brevi tutorial dove vi
mostrerò appunto il trucco che mi facevo alle medie al liceo e all'università
Partiamo subito con il trucco delle medie allora non, so voi ma io alle medie
Chiaramente non mi truccavo in maniera pesante perché mia mamma a parte che mi
Nascondeva tipo il primo e il secondo anno delle medie mi nascondeva. I trucchi quindi io me li compravo e non li trovavo più e me li nascondeva
Se proprio mi truccavo, mi truccavo poco
per farsi che mia mamma non se ne accorgesse perché non era molto d'accordo
E in particolare prediligevo i colori pastello
rosa azzurra erano i prescelti
Quindi vi farò vedere più o meno come mi conciavo per andare a scuola
Sto male perché veramente ragazzi era inguardabile, ah premetto ogni tanto mi mettevo anche le lentine colorate azzurre
Sembrava un alieno una cosa atroce! non chiedetemi come sia possibile che io abbia questi ombretti infatti sono
non sono mai stati utilizzati come potete notare perché questi colori come avrete visto nei miei vari make up, non
Li uso mai, però almeno mi servono  per fare questo video! allora partirei con l'azzurro che era il prescelto appunto perché faceva pendant
faceva coordinato con le lentine e lo andrei a stendere tutto
tutto senza un motivo, su tutta la palpebra fissa, mobile
non mobile, insomma
Dipingiamo l'occhio cosí, questo azzurro non si vede tanto, forse ne ho altri
Un'altra palette di azzurri e blu ma da dove é uscita?
Adesso sì questo sì che è un ombretto per le medie. Più o meno l'effetto
dell'ombretto era questo quindi molto molto glamour molto fashion
E cosa succedeva che quando ero fortunata e quindi riuscivo a trovare il nascondiglio di mia mamma dove metteva
Il mascara che mi compravo e puntualmente nascondeva mi mettevo anche un filo di mascara ma giusto un filo
per far sì che non, si notasse e
la cosa diciamo più fashion era il lucidalabbra che trovavo solitamente nel Cioè e di solito
aveva un colore simile a questo quindi andiamo subito di lucidalabbra
già sotto mi ero messa il rosa
peró il lucidalabbra era il tocco diciamo top
questo sì che è un make up ragazzi dai!
Se era il giorno magari della foto di classe cioè proprio gli eventoni ci poteva stare anche un pó di
Rosa sulle guance no? Ed è subito Heidi!!
Che carina! Poi tra l'altro vedete quello che sta succedendo : i capelli che si attaccano al lucidalabbra? Mi succedeva sempre e mi
veniva sempre il nervoso. Poi se ero proprio in vena di
conquistare il ragazzino che mi piaceva mi mettevo anche un po di fard che rubavo a mia sorella ed era subito Claudia Schiffer insomma
questo tutorial é top!
Clio
ormai ti ho rubato il lavoro perché questo make up tutorial é il make up della vita
ma passiamo subito a un make up un pó meno traumatico che era quello, del liceo cioè che fa sempre schifo però diciamo non ero con un cartone animato
Ed eccoci giunti al momento
Più top del video cioè il momento top adoro perché praticamente questo non è uno scherzo, ma effettivamente é la base che mi facevo
al liceo
Diciamola tutta in realtà mi facevo anche parecchie lampade però per risparmiare non facevo il lettino ma facevo soltanto il viso quindi
diventavo arancione in faccia e tutto il resto del corpo era bianco! Era molto diciamo un antenato del Jersey Shore il mio make up
del liceo. La cosa bella appunto proseguendo questo make up tutorial era che invece il correttore
era chiaramente chiaro che qui anche qui non dimentichiamo che doveva essere messo intorno a tutto l'occhio così faceva bene l'effetto
appunto tipo "sono andata a fare una settimana in montagna
quindi ho il segno della mascherina"! Questo era veramente da fighi questa cosa
non so perché come oro nero adesso io al liceo ero hashtag marrone qualsiasi cosa era marrone : i vestiti,
il trucco, le unghie, qualsiasi cosa non so perché ero fissata con sto marrone, forse andava di moda, non
ricordo sta di fatto che chiaramente l'ombretto era rigorosamente
Marrone! Ecco il mio ombretto marrone che tra l'altro penso sia proprio
risalga proprio a quel periodo della mia vita che oserei chiamare
CHOCO POPS
Lo applicavo tra l'altro é un marrone molto scuro, lo applicavo vedete, su tutta la palpebra mobile
Però aspettate il giochino qual era
era appunto fare tipo la punta qui vedete quindi una specie di smokey eye occhio da gatta
però era tutto marrone non é che dici sfumo non sfumo no non era sfumato era così
e la cosa fondamentale se volete riprodurre questo make up e non sfumarlo
perché era giusto
tenerlo così
potevo non mettere la matita
rigorosamente vediamo se indovinate
MARRONE
quindi la matita marrone andava dentro l'occhio
Io avevo questo metodo che tutte le mie amiche
mi chiedevano come facessi, io mettevo la matita, chiudevo l'occhio, andavo avanti e indietro ed era subito effetto
kajal, vedete?
Per essere ancor più trasgressive c'è stato un periodo in cui alternavo matita viola a matita verdone che voi direte e dove la metti?
fuori! chiaramente quindi dentro marrone fuori
viola
il mascara, lo mettevo rigorosamente marrone chiaramente però non ce l'ho più
Devo dire che col mascara é cambiato tutto, adesso sì che un vero trucco chiaramente nonostante già fossi color
Escremento per non dire un'altra parola
cosa facevo? caricavo tantissimo col fard che non mettiamo solo qui attenzione
Perché ai tempi avevo un pennellone non fatto cosí, era proprio quello grosso
considerate una roba così però
ancora più grossa, io proprio spolveravo
completamente il viso con questo pennellone
A volte quando ero fortunata mi accorgevo che le orecchie erano bianche quindi passavo
anche il fard sulle orecchie che quindi rimanevano di un colore piú simile all'incarnato
peró il collo mai, il collo mi ricordo di non averlo
mai notato particolarmente bianco
le labbra erano un po meno tremende perché di solito mettevo semplicemente il lucidalabbra
Questo qua tra l'altro risale veramente , dovrei buttarlo, risale veramente a decenni a decenni fa
Sono un mostro vero? allora sciogli le trecce ai cavalli, sciogliamo
Perché di solito andavo coi capelli sciolti
Non mi faccevo quasi mai la piega, me li asciugavo semplicemente così, così erano belli crespi e
questa era Maryna al liceo
Siate carini nei commenti qui sotto
non massacratemi
Passiamo subito a un look decisamente più sobrio, quasi nullo che era quello
dell'università, eccoci arrivati all'ultimo make up nonchè il più sobrio, grazie a dio, che era quello cheti  facevo per andare all'università
chi non conoscesse il mondo universitario
Sappiate che i primi due tre giorni andrete tutte tirate, tutte carine, un pó insomma come andavate al liceo
dopodiché capirete che praticamente
se volete seguire tutte le lezioni, se volete passare
gli esami, non avrete neanche tempo di pensare a cosa mettervi o come truccarvi perché sarà tutto un pó come dire
un casino ecco insomma diciamo che il mondo universitario
è un po diverso dal liceo
Ma faremo un video a parte dove vi spiegherò
la mia esperienza universitaria, per adesso concentriamoci sul make up! allora per andare all'università diciamo
che il mio make up era molto molto semplice, di base appunto perché ero di fretta e tutto mi concentravo
sulla base appunto, quindi fondotinta, correttore per coprire le occhiaie che arrivavano a terra. Per quanto riguarda gli occhi era una roba proprio
base cioè, nel senso mi mettevo la matita marrone
sopra così tipo
prendevo un pennellino me la sfumavo un pó, cioè proprio il trucco dell'ultimo minuto
mascara proprio al volo
neanche troppo cioè proprio un filo e poi mettevo questo rossetto che risale forse ai tempi dell'università
velvet teddy di mac
Sicuramente un pochino di
fard qua sugli zigomi
E poi mi portavo dietro il correttore
Perché se mi andava via insomma il punto cruciale del mio make up delll'università era coprire le occhiaie e le borse sotto
gli occhi spero che anche voi universitarie mi
capirete in questo momento, spero tantissimo che questo video sui miei make up
passati diciamo vi sia piaciuto, ma soprattutto vi abbia divertito. Quando mi dite no vabbè sei bravissima a truccarti, ecco ragazze diciamo che
ne ho passate di fasi di make up non sempre sono stata così insomma
capace a truccarmi, non
che io mi reputi una make up artist però diciamo che adesso
dei trucchi del genere non me li faccio. Come al solito se vi è piaciuto
il video ricordatevi di
se non siete ancora iscritti, iscrivervi proprio
all'istante per vedere tutti i miei video e attivare la campanella che trovate vicino al tasso d'iscrizione per rimanere sempre aggiornati sulle mie novità
E soprattutto di seguirmi anche su tutti gli altri social quindi instagram
musically e facebook vi mando un bacione e top adoro!!!